deux grandes énigmes judiciaires
reviennent sur le devant de la scène
avec tout d'abord un rebondissement dans
la sphère du requin disparu à nice en
mars 91 à l'âge de 8 ans et présumés
morts
charles-edouard turquin aurait été
aperçu en israël cet été un nouvel
élément qui a entraîné le report du
procès prévu en mars du père du petit
garçon inculpé d'assassinât sur la base
d'un aveu qu'il réfute les faits avec
sont gratuites
nous sommes en février 92
incarcéré pendant neuf mois jean-louis
turquin retrouvent la liberté après une
grève de la faim et une caution de 400
mille francs
le vétérinaire niçois est inculpé pour
l'assassinât de son fils charles édouard
huit ans disparus sans laisser de traces
sa femme a enregistré son aveu à son
insu aujourd'hui l'accusation demeure et
jean-louis turquin qui continue de nier
les faits restent sous contrôle
judiciaire
une période pendant laquelle il va
recourir aux services d'un détective
privé
la filature de la mère de charles
edouard l'emmènera jusqu'à en israël en
août dernier un mois plus tard
jean-louis turquin son détective
recueilli des témoignages capitaux dans
un kibboutz au sud de tel-aviv de
personnes ont vu michel turquin avec un
garçon d'une dizaine d'années et une
institutrice souviendrai d'un petit
charles édouard rester dans sa classe
quelques semaines des éléments transmis
au président de la cour d'assises des
alpes-maritimes toute mesure qui permet
d'aider la justice en réalité la vo
thanh auxiliaires de la justice afin de
tenter de retrouver la trace de cet
enfant doit être essayés et doit être
approuvée le président de la cour
d'assises a donc ordonné un complément
d'information et une commission
rogatoire va permettre aux policiers
israéliens d'interroger ces nouveaux
témoins un sursis de quelques mois pour
jean-louis turquin son côté ne pourra
pas avoir lieu avant le mois de mai